The top three countries in the world with
the best healthcare systems
No. 3 Germany.
Covering 100% of the population,
Germany allocates about 11.7% of its GDP to healthcare.
The German system is known for its short waiting times,
access to the latest medical technologies
and a high density of doctors,
with approximately 4.3 physicians per 1,000 residents.
No. 2 Switzerland
Switzerland consistently ranks among
the top countries in healthcare
due to its universal health coverage system
where 99% of the population is insured.
Switzerland boasts high quality medical services
in advanced technology.
Its healthcare expenditure is around 12% of GDP.
Before revealing the number one,
remember to subscribe and like the video!
Number one Japan.
Japan has the highest health score in the world
with a life expectancy of 85 years.
Japan's healthcare system is based on mandatory
social health insurance,
which covers almost all medical services.
The government regulates
the fees and quality of healthcare providers,
ensuring equal access for all. And you,
do you have a good healthcare system where you're at?
Let me know in the comments.